PAM BONDI CERTAINLY HOPES THEY
GO DEATH PENALTY.
>> AND NOW ONTO AN EYEWITNESS.
A STUDENT WHO WAS AT STONEMAN
DOUGLAS AS THIS HORRIFIC EVENT
UNFOLDED.
DAVID, FIRST OF ALL, OUR
THOUGHTS -- THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
SOUND AFTER A WHILE VERY TRITE
AND CLICHE, BUT AS I WAS IN MY
KITCHEN WATCHING THIS TODAY, AND
I HAVE THREE KIDS, YOU JUST WANT
TO BREAK DOWN AND CRY.
BUT THERE’S SO MUCH BRAVERY ON
THE PART OF STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS, ACCORDING TO RECORDS,
ONE DIED.
THAT DOES GIVE US SOME HOPE IN
HUMANITY.
BUT TELL US WHAT HAPPENED AND
WHAT YOU HEARD UNFOLD AS YOU
WERE IN SCHOOL TODAY.
>> SO THE FIRST THING THAT I
HEARD WAS ONE SINGLE GUNSHOT.
WE INITIALLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
DRILL BUT IT TURNED OUT TO BE
ANYTHING BUT.
AFTER WE HEARD THE FIRST
GUNSHOT, WE HEADED DOWN THE WAY.
WE STARTED HEADING TOWARDS OUR
DESIGNATED ZONE FOR THE FIRE.
ANYWAYS, ON OUR WAY THERE, WE
STARTED SEEING A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
RUNNING AND STARTED RUNNING WITH
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
BUT LITTLE DID WE KNOW AT THE
TIME, WE WERE ACTUALLY RUNNING
TOWARDS THE SCHOOL SHOOTER.
BUT LUCKILY FOR THE HEROIC
ACTIONS OF THE SCHOOL JANITOR,
THEY SAVED OUR LIVES.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR ACTIONS,
THEY SAVED --
>>AND ARE THEY OKAY, DAVID?
>> YES.
RIGHT NOW, AS FAR AS I KNOW,
WHEN WE LEFT THEY WERE OKAY.
I HAVEN’T HEARD ANYTHING
OTHERWISE.
BUT ALL THE STUDENTS ARE FINE.
>> AND, DAVID, YOU’RE A STUDENT
JOURNALIST.
YOU’RE WRITING IN SCHOOL, WHICH
IS INCREDIBLY HELPFUL BECAUSE
YOU’RE OBSERVING EVERYTHING.
DID YOU KNOW THE SHOOTER?
AND IF YOU DID NOT, DO YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO KNEW HIM AND WHAT
WERE THEIR OBSERVATIONS ABOUT
HIM?
>> YES.
I DID NOT KNOW THE SHOOTER
PERSONALLY BUT I KNOW MANY
PEOPLE THAT DID KNOW HIM.
WHAT I’VE HEARD ABOUT HIM IS
THAT HE WAS A PERSON THAT WAS
VERY OFFSET, KIND OF AWKWARD.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE INTERESTING
STORIES ABOUT HIM THAT WERE
REALLY QUITE AWKWARD FROM THEIR
TIME IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND JUST A
REALLY PRECARIOUS KIND OF OFFISH
GUY.
>> DID YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
HIS FAMILY, HIS UPBRINGING,
OTHER SIBLINGS, PROBLEMS AT
HOME?
WAS HE IS SOCIAL PARIAH,
NOBODIES TALKED TO HIM AND HE
WAS REALLY ISOLATED?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, HE WAS A
VERY ISOLATED PERSON SOCIALLY.
HE DID NOT INTERACT WITH MANY
PEOPLE.
HE SEEMED TO HAVE A SOMEWHAT
MESSED-UP PERSONAL LIFE AT HOME.
AND THAT’S AS FAR AS I KNOW.
AND I’VE HEARD THAT FROM
MULTIPLE PEOPLE.
>> THERE WERE OTHER REPORTS
THAT HE HAD THREATENED AT LEAST
AND KIND OF JOKINGLY, THAT I
COULD TAKE ALL OF YOU OUT.
AND HE KNEW THE LAYOUT OF THE
SCHOOL.
HE KNEW THE EVACUATION DRILLS.
HE WAS UP ON THAT THIRD FLOOR
WHEN HE PULLED THE ALARM.
HE KNEW THE LAYOUT.
HE KNEW WHERE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
TO GO, CORRECT?
>> EXACTLY.
AND THE AMAZING THING IS,
BECAUSE OF THE HEROIC AND MORE
OR LESS THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
BROWARD COUNTY SCHOOLS TO MAKE
IT A MORE SAFE SCHOOL IN THE
PAST MONTHS IN RESPONSE TO THESE
MASS SHOOTINGS IN SCHOOLS,
THEY’VE TRAINED ALL OF THE
TEACHERS RECENTLY TO LOCK ALL OF
THE DOORS IN CASE A HORRIFYING
INCIDENT LIKE THIS HAPPENS,
WE’RE AS SAFE AS WE CAN BE.
AND I THINK THAT TRAINING SAVED
HUNDREDS OF LIVES TODAY.
>> ARE THERE ANY SCHOOL
OFFICIALS THE OR OTHER THAN A
SECURITY GUARD WHO ARE ARMED
INSIDE THE SCHOOL THAT YOU KNOW
OF?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, THERE IS A
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER THAT I
BELIEVE IS ARMED.
BUT I DIDN’T HEAR MUCH ABOUT HIM
OR ANYTHING THAT HE DID DURING
THIS EVENT.
OBVIOUSLY, I’M SURE HE WAS DOING
ALL HE COULD.
BUT AS FAR AS I KNOW, I HAVEN’T
HEARD MUCH ABOUT HIM.
BUT I’M SURE THE MEDIA KNOWS
MORE THAN I DO.
>> TELL US ABOUT THAT GAZEBO
AREA WHERE CERTAIN KIDS SIT IN
THE LUNCHROOM.
OWENS GAZEBO OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT WHERE SOME OF THE OUTCASTS
SIT.
HE WASN’T EVEN WELCOME IN THAT
AREA WHERE, AGAIN, IT WAS IN
SOCIAL MEDIA, SOME OF THE FREAKS
IN SCHOOL SIT BECAUSE THEY’RE
NOT ACCEPTED IN THE REST OF THE
SCHOOL.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
>> YEAH.
SO HE SAT IN AN AREA THAT SADLY
MANY STUDENTS REFER TO AS -- I’M
NOT GOING TO SAY IT ON TV.
BUT IT’S AN AREA WHERE VERY
UNIQUE KIDS SIT AND CHILDREN
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN THINGS
THAT ARE MORE EXTRACURRICULAR
AND OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL AND HAVE
AMAZING INTERESTS AND ARE JUST
AS VALUABLE AS ANY STUDENT IN
THIS SCHOOL.
BUT THE FACT THAT HE WAS
OUTCASTED BY THOSE PEOPLE, I
WOULD SAY IT DOESN’T SAY A LOT.
BUT ACTUALLY, IT DOES SAY A LOT
BECAUSE HERE AT STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL, WE LIKE TO ACCEPT
EVERYONE FOR WHO THEY ARE.
WE LIKE TO BRING EVERYONE IN AND
JUST EMBRACE WHO THEY ARE.
AND SADLY WITH THIS PERSON, HE
DIDN’T FEEL THAT WAY.
HE DIDN’T FEEL ACCEPTED.
AND THAT MAY HAVE BEEN PART OF
THE REASON WHY HE DID THIS
HORRIBLE ATROCITY THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAVE HAPPENED.
>> ISOLATED.
ISOLATED.
IN ONE CASE, HE DESCRIBED
HIMSELF AS BEING BULLIED.
DID YOU HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT?
THAT HE WAS BULLIED BY ONE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL.
>> I DIDN’T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
BULLYING.
HE DOES SEEM LIKE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD HAVE HAD A ROUGH TIME
IN SCHOOL BASED OFF OF HIS
PREVIOUS ACTIONS.
INTERESTING AND WEIRD COMMENTS
MADE TO PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
EVEN ONE OF HIS TUTORS.
>> WHAT WAS THE COMMENT?
WHAT WAS THAT COMMENT?
>> IT WAS ACTUALLY -- I DON’T
WANT TO GO -- THIS PERSON TOLD
ME NOT TO TELL ANYONE.
>> YOU DON’T HAVE TO IDENTIFY
ANYBODY.
BUT WHAT WAS THE COMMENT?
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> THE COMMENT WAS A REQUEST
FOR SEXUAL RELATIONS WITH A
STUDENT.
>> MM.
>> AND IT WAS VERY AWKWARD,
ACCORDING TO THEM.
>> YEAH.
AND OBVIOUSLY PROBABLY OBVIOUSLY
REJECTED.
DAVID, INCREDIBLY POISED
DELIVERY OF INFORMATION TONIGHT.
AND OUR EMOTIONS --
>>CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING TO
THE AUDIENCE?
>> YES.
>> YEAH.
I DON’T WANT THIS TO BE ANOTHER
MASS SHOOTING.
I DON’T WANT THIS JUST TO BE
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE FORGET.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO LOOK AT AND REALIZE THAT
THERE IS A SERIOUS ISSUE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT WE ALL NEED TO
FACE.
IT’S AN ISSUE THAT AFFECTS EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF US.
AND IF YOU THINK IT DOESN’T,
BELIEVE ME, IT WILL, ESPECIALLY
IF WE DON’T TAKE ACTION TO STEP
UP.
LIKE GOING TO YOUR CONGRESSMAN
AND ASKING FOR HELP AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.